[Music]
i met this girl
hi hi uh i'm mark dude i saw you last
night you didn't tell me anything about
a girl this is gonna sound really
strange i was
wondering are you experiencing any kind
of temporal anomaly
listen we're stuck in a time loop you me
everybody same day's repeating over and
over again like in groundhog day and
edge of tomorrow except only me and this
girl margaret know about it but you
don't remember any of this because your
brain keeps getting erased
oh so what have you brought to with
infinite time oh you know like
solving crimes and teaching myself how
to drive
i thought so you're into her well like
i'm not not
into her you ever wish today happened on
a different day
just hoping we could talk about your
future besides who knows what they want
to be when they're 17.
i do aerospace engineer specifically a
nasa mission specialist
wait like an astronaut because that's
cool that's like uh
most of life is just jump and then
there's these moments and all the
randomness turns into something perfect
that is disturbingly inspirational what
if we found them all
all the perfect things we could collect
them like partners
oh yeah can i tell you a secret
with you i don't have to pretend
what is this
he made a map of us
i should go
[Music]
we could get out of it are you really in
that much of a hurry
you don't actually think that this is
living do you we have all the time in
the world
this is not time time is the stuff that
when you spend it you don't get it back
i thought everything was perfect but
there was more to the story
[Music]
i thought we'd have so much more time
[Music]
you